problem solving skills is about your
analytical abilities it is about cutting
through complexity of complex business
challenges you can also talk about how
you solve the complex interpersonal
challenge talk about how you can solve
problems that other people cannot solve
in the last Dimension is your leadership
ability so maybe you're an experienced
higher and already had some leadership
experience in the past with actual
teammates in the job or if you're fresh
out of University maybe in University
you were a leading member of a club so
here talk about how you were able to
motivate other people to create a team
and as a team effort to get things done
this from my perspective is leadership
and this is what will be valued by
consulting firms